what is on the- nose Dialogue on the-
nose dialogue is dialogue that's too
direct and straightforward it doesn't
give the audience anything interesting
to think about often we can find on the
nose dialogue where the character is
saying exactly what he means with no
space in between the text what he's
saying and the subtext what he means if
I'm in love with you and I say I'm in
love with you that dialogue is directly
on the nose I'm telling you exactly what
I mean and for the audience watching
unless it's a very special moment that's
probably not a very interesting moment
because
nothing nothing is being challenged
everything's a little bit too
easy if I say to you would you like to
have a cup of coffee with me and
everybody understands I'm really saying
I love you then I've taken dialogue
that's on the nose and moved it off the
nose I've given an inference or a
suggestion of what I mean without
stating what I mean
directly as a point of Interest I can
tell you two different ways to say this
phrase in other languages oh please yes
in Spanish it's deas oio too obvious
they don't have a metaphor for it but in
Russian it is the beautiful schlish vlob
schom vlob that means too much
forehead which is their way of saying on
the
nose and often the difference between
okay writing and great writing can be
found in the distance between what is
being said and what is being felt so
dialogue that's on the nose is generally
not satisfying because it doesn't give
the audience anything to work with or
think about the subtext of would you
like to have a cup of coffee then we
could subvert the audience's
Expectations by I meet you for coffee
and it turns out you're presenting me
with some kind of multi-level marketing
thing that you want me to be a part of
and I thought you were going to propose
there you go so I got all excited told
all my girlfriends I think he's the one
because I I read misread his subtext
clearly he's asking me for coffee that
means he's he wants to marry me right um
how do you get that sister because I'm
not sure you're interpreting reality
correctly you might be filtering more
through hope than reality which makes it
interesting for the character I want
this guy I want this guy to propose to
me but he won't do it and I want him to
propose to me so badly that I'll invent
circumstances where he will
suddenly I am thinking about a movie
called The Proposal
Chaser which is the story of a young
woman who wants her boyfriend to commit
to propose and thinks up all of these
outlandish
situations where she kind of tries to
Corner him into proposing and he doesn't
do it and he won't do it and finally
she's at the point of saying I can't
never make this relationship work I was
wrong to think that I
could I have to let go of my expectation
that he's going to give me what I want
and just just accept him as I am as he
is and that's the moment where
everything changes and opens the door to
the Happy Ending what if a writer gets a
note that all of their characters sound
the same if all of my characters are
sounding the same to the reader it must
be that I haven't delved into them
enough to make them sound
different I can assume that it's a
problem that they all sound the same if
it if it's not a problem that's great if
they say all of your characters sound
the same and we love it like great
problem solved let's pay me and I'll go
on to my next project but if they're
saying the problem with the script is
that the characters all sound the same
then I have a problem my first problem
in the moment is ouch my feelings you
just told me something bad about my work
and I feel bad now that's me processing
information through ego I'm asking how
does this information make me feel
that's not going to get the problem
solved that's just going to make me feel
bad they hate me they think I can't
write multi-dimensional characters or
different characters this sucks I suck
it's the end of the
world so in the moment when they're
giving me these notes I'm making a
different Choice I'm not filtering
through ego I'm filtering through the
work I'm asking what information are
they giving me and how can I use the
information they're giving me to improve
the work now we can pass through the
notion that I don't think they're right
I don't think the characters sound the
same I think they all sound different
but if it's a situation where they're
giving me notes and I have to work from
those notes then I'm going to say to
myself if they're right how are they
right what is their problem well it
looks like these two characters I don't
think they sound the same because their
comic tones are quite different oh but I
do see that they agree with each other
on what's a great TV show they both love
this one show and there's no story
purpose for it it's just a fact they're
too similar in that sense they love the
same things okay I can start to solve
the problem by rethinking the characters
and saying they don't love the same
thing they hate they love love different
things so they each hate what the other
loves I made a different choice now I'm
in a space where I can start to give the
characters different comic filters more
exaggerated comic filters and separate
them move them off in different
directions there's a good example of
characters who are very close to one
another who you would think would sound
the same and you kind of wonder how they
ended up not sounding the same it's Joey
and Phoebe from friends because Joey's
comic filter is Teflon brain nothing
sticks to his brain he's pretty dumb
pretty but dumb no just pretty dumb
Phoebe's comic filter is naive innocence
she's not dumb she's not unsmart she's
not unsophisticated she's just naive and
in fact she's naive as a defense
mechanism which is an interesting thing
about the character just like Joey is
dumb as a defense mechanism to protect
him against the allegation that he's
dumb weirdly enough so we have two
characters who are very similar in tone
they would both respond to things
generally in a sense of I don't
understand what I'm looking at but they
would respond to it for two very
different reasons Joey because he
doesn't have the cultural information to
solve the problem that he's looking at
and Phoebe because she won't allow
herself to think about things in a
sophisticated self-aware
way she she will adhere to herself
self-image for the sake of self-
protection that's another interesting
thing about Comic characters they will
always serve their self-image above
their
self-interest it's a really interesting
thing characters will do things that are
bad for them if they think it'll make
them feel good how important is it for
characters in a comedy to tell jokes
that seems like a loaded question but
the answer is is really it's not
important characters generally should
not be telling jokes unless it's in
their character to tell jokes and a lot
of beginning writers kind of make this
mistake they're writing a sitcom they
have a joke they
love and they kind of force it into a
character's mouth doesn't really belong
in the character's mouth but they know
it's a Surefire joke and they think it's
the job of the page to be funny and they
think that the presence of the joke will
be funny but that's not the character
being funny that's the writer telling a
joke if it's built into the character's
nature to tell jokes then you can tell
jokes all day we were just talking about
friends and we can think about Chandler
and Friends the first episode he says I
use comedy as a defense mechanism I
protect myself by telling jokes he's not
hiding it he tells us right there in the
first episode that that's who he is so
when that character makes a joke it's
never for the sake of the joke it's
never for the sake of making the
audience laugh it's for the sake of
making the AUD character feel good about
himself so when I as the writer put a
joke into to the script for the sake of
making the audience laugh and basically
ignoring what the characters are and
what their needs are if it's not
appropriate for them to tell jokes and I
throw jokes in there the audience is
going to say why is that happening I
don't understand what's going on but if
I want to tell jokes I will build
telling jokes into the nature of the
character I wrote a spec episode we know
that Quantum Leap is back my career goes
back so far that I wrote a spec episode
of Quantum Leap oh back in the day and I
built it around the story of the
character leaping into a stand-up comic
why cuz I knew I had some quality in
telling jokes and I knew I'd have to
write some stand-up comedy material
sooner or later in that script and so it
was a way of playing to my strength I
created a character and I created a
situation that would let me tell jokes
organically cuz telling jokes was
something I was good
at I hear myself saying that cuz telling
jokes is something I was good at and I
realized that sounds so not funny I was
like I don't know where you got so
analytical John vorous but I can't
imagine back in the day that you were
much different than you are now so were
you really that
funny